if you've seen toy story 4 you've
probably noticed that pixar's animation
doesn't neglect any detail no matter how
small from dust particles in the antique
shop to subtle signs of aging on the
toys it's all there rendered incredibly
realistically on the big screen
so how exactly did pixar bring this
intricate world to life
let's take a look at the fascinating
process that created toy story 4 from
start to finish
[Music]
for toy story 4 as for all pixar films
story comes first while the writers
draft the script story artists work
alongside them making preliminary
sketches for each scene in the film
these sketches called storyboards give
the pixar team an idea of how each scene
will go down
editors then cut the storyboards
together into an animatic or story reel
basically a long detailed flip book that
reflects the pace of each sequence
the story reel is edited with
rudimentary sound effects a scratch
soundtrack and temporary dialogue that's
been pre-recorded by pixar employees it
serves as a rough draft for the movie
allowing the filmmakers to get an idea
of how the story will unfold and hone
the sequences before having them
animated once the storyline is set the
art department and production designers
get together to create concept art for
the characters and their environments
meanwhile character artists lay out how
each toy will look in the film
for toy story 4 character design
involved a lot of research into the toys
themselves how they're made how they age
and everything in between the character
team found their perfect villain on
field trips to antique shops where
they'd often spot vintage dolls lurking
in corners
there the idea for gabby gabby was born
this newcomer is a talking doll from the
1950s and she's designed to come off as
very toy like in a way that might even
give you the creeps at first
on the other hand it's all warm fuzzies
when we meet ducky and bunny a pair of
carnival prize toys voiced by keegan
michael key and jordan peele their loud
bright colors cheap looking plush and
sheen finish were designed to look
authentic for the kind of toy you'd win
at a carnival game not the highest in
quality but lovable nonetheless the
character artists also decide on
wardrobe they steered clear from any
major changes to most of the toy's
signature costumes
but they wanted to update beau peep's
look to reflect her resourcefulness and
sense of adventure
aspects of her character that weren't
fully explored in the earlier toy
stories
so they came up with a convertible
costume that allowed beau to repurpose
elements of her outfit on the fly even
turning her dress into a bag or a cape
when it suits her
another key step in the visual
development of the film is the creation
of color scripts these digital
illustrations that kind of look like
impressionist paintings from the 19th
century
each picture depicts a single frame in
the movie helping filmmakers start to
define the style lighting scheme and
general mood of each shot and figure out
how the colors in each scene will relate
to the overall storyline all of these
illustrations provide reference material
for the next stage of computer modeling
this is when the toys and their
environments begin to take form in
three-dimensional space
modeling artists take the basic shapes
of the characters sets and props and
mold them into a 3d mesh then sculpt and
refine these builds until they're
satisfied in constructing the sets scale
was a chief concern
as the artist wanted to accurately
represent the diminutive size of the
toys relative to their surroundings to
nail down that contrast they photograph
models of the toys interacting with
objects out in the real world then use
those photos for reference
the character models require an extra
step so uh how long is this going to
take you can't rush art
they get rigged with a movable skeleton
which has controls placed around its
face its joints and the rest of its body
like a really advanced digital puppet
animators will then be able to
manipulate the character's movement
using its unique set of controls making
it act and emote in precise ways as the
story requires so the characters can now
move and they have sets to move around
in but something's missing neither the
characters nor their sets have any
surface characteristics making
everything kind of fall flat
that's where shading or surfacing comes
in shading artist's job is to furnish
the 3d models with the kind of textures
finishes and tints they'd have in real
life lending them visual complexity and
charm some of this work is done using
shaders computer programs that know how
to simulate a range of materials like
plastic fabric metal wood glass hair or
skin clever software proved useful for
the 10 000 items that filled the antique
shop shading art director laura phillips
said her team saved time by developing a
language of three different ages for the
many items in the store fairly new
moderately aged and extremely aged
they applied varying degrees of texture
to the objects according to that visual
language but a lot of the shading was
done by hand especially for the most
central invisible items like the
carnival game where buzz accidentally
lands himself the sets team reasoned
that in a traveling carnival games like
this one would have to be quickly
assembled torn down and stowed away so
they'd probably look a little beaten up
to capture that artist painted welding
marks on the grid backdrop of the booth
this fit the game's shabby look with its
slightly warped metal bars and visible
rusting
[Music]
of course special attention was also
lavished on the shading of the
characters for plastic toys like woody
and buzz the shading artists created an
algorithm to simulate the effect of
light penetrating a slightly translucent
surface such as plastic meanwhile they
added subtle signs of wear and tear to
the toys to reflect their histories the
threads on woody's clothes have started
fraying there are dirt smudges on his
hand and chin and the seam on his vest
has worn thin
buzz has plenty of scratches of his own
especially near his joints and his
stickers have begun to bubble pucker and
peel you can also see felt poking out of
certain spots on jessie's hat
these specific scuffs towards the front
of gabby's shoes could only result from
the distinct walking style of an older
doll like her the scratch effect on
forky's cheeks indicates his past life
as an eating utensil and bose porcelain
shows signs of crazing the type of micro
cracks that appear in the glaze of
ceramics
now that the characters have started
looking more tangible and real the cast
members visit the studio to record their
voice performances the sessions are
filmed so that the actors expressions
can guide their characters facial
animations later on
before that though is layout when the
characters are set up in front of a
virtual camera
layout artists in an animated movie
function similarly as a camera team
would in any live-action movie guided by
the storyboards they place the
characters appearing in a scene into the
appropriate set arrange the characters
in front of the camera and block out
their basic movements within the right
camera angles
at this point the sets may not be
completely dressed yet meaning more
props might be added later on but layout
helps the set dressers determine the
best placement of every object within
the composition of each shot
once the scenes have been staged the
animation team gets them moving bringing
all the primary and secondary characters
to life
[Music]
each character is defined by up to one
thousand avars or hinges that are built
into their skeleton if the animators are
like puppeteers and the characters are
their puppets the avars represent the
strings on a puppet points of possible
movement that the animators manipulate
to make their characters act and emote
every day the animation department comes
together to analyze the one or two
seconds of film they've just put into
motion and talk about ways they can make
those few seconds even more expressive
since the shots and pixar films are so
complex it can take 8 weeks or more to
animate a single shot the character
animation is also highly specific the
way each character moves in toy story 4
was informed by what type of toy they
were and what personality traits they
gave off
the story and character artists imagined
the bow peep of toy story 4 as a kind of
graceful agile road warrior so the
animators looked to reference footage of
ballroom dancer sharna burgess gymnast
ali riceman and the bride from kill bill
the way beau wields her shepherd's hook
was informed by footage of javelin
throwers martial arts pros
and of course rey from star wars in
contrast animators gave gabby gabby more
doll-like movement that be consistent
with an old-fashioned pole string doll
of her variety her weighted eyes blink
slowly closing when she's horizontal and
she mostly moves from joints in her hips
shoulders and neck
while the animation team choreographs
characters movements and facial
expressions by hand the simulation team
uses computer programs to lay down the
movement of other elements like fur
weather or clothing
these phenomena interact with other
components of a shot in ways that are
largely defined by
science how much does a cat's hair move
how fast do raindrops fall how much does
a specific garment shrink or stretch
pixar builds physics-based simulators
that govern how these textures should
behave on screen
this saves the animators from doing
impossible tasks by hand
like for instance animating each strand
of hair on gabi's head individually of
course simulation isn't solely dictated
by science the sim team balances math
and physics against artistic
considerations
one example is the fur on ducky and
bunny
its behavior is largely based on ostrich
feathers and the fake feathers used on
the muppets but according to simulation
supervisor henry garcia they found that
ducky's tuft was ten percent funnier if
they let it stay alive a little bit
longer after he stops moving
the result is adorable once the motion
feels alive and believable the lighting
team comes in to illuminate the
characters and sets
using software that mimics the physics
of light pixar adds hundreds of virtual
light sources to each scene the lights
are strategically placed to draw
attention to story points or to
cultivate a certain mood
the antique shop for example appears
bright towards the front but grows dark
as you move deeper into the store
heightening the drama
tonal variation is important bonnie's
school appears cool and intimidating at
first but that changes once she gets to
her classroom there's warm light
streaming through the window where she
creates forky emphasizing the birth of
new life the carnival lighting
establishes a very different energy with
multi-colored marquee lights and ferris
wheel lights creating a sense of chaos
and excitement
and inside the pinball machine low level
lighting and fog create a cool aura
making it feel like an ideal hangout
spot for the toys
after all the images are lit rendering
gets underway this is when all of the
digital data that makes up the motion
picture gets translated into actual
frames of film 24 of them for each
second of the movie
at last it's time for the final touches
on shading lighting and effects
it's up to the effects artist to perfect
the amount of dust and atmosphere in
each image
varying the levels until they get their
ideal look that of course depends on
setting they wanted a lot of dust
particulates in the antique shop while
at the carnival they emphasized the dirt
kicked up from the ground
they also gave the air around the toys a
richer texture than the air around the
human characters to highlight just how
tiny these toys really were
after the final frames are rendered the
film gets scored and sound mixed
five years and many many late nights
later the fourth toy story is finally
ready for viewing
pixar's painstaking attention to detail
draws the audience into the unique world
perspective of the toys and makes
watching toy story 4 a totally immersive
experience
[Music]
you